the reds are sending right-hander luis
castillo to the mound the former marlin
farmhand the reds are 65 and 57. and now
the batter is isan diaz
overall this year hitting 209 he has
four home runs and 15 rbis now the
runner takes off the pitch is down an in
throw from the knees of stevenson on
target and in time to farmer to gun down
miguel rojas just the second time this
year that rojas has been caught stealing
why an amazing throw there by tyler
stevenson rojas had a huge lead and i
mean his jump was as big from here to
tomorrow and from the knees tyler
stevenson throws a very strong throw and
a slap tag by kyle farmer just in time
castillo's home with a 1-2 pitch swing
going to miss change-up and he had diaz
way out in front
he strikes out two away now in the first
inning nick knight on the bound for the
marlins tonight at great american ball
park in cincinnati the marlins are 51-70
rookie of the year favorite jonathan
india 277 average 16 home runs 55 rbis
terrific on base percentage and may have
catapulted himself with a strong second
half into the top spot in the rookie of
the year however will not come up with a
hit here thanks to brian anderson and a
beautiful play
diving to his left to take one away from
india first and third one out alex
jackson it might be one of those
situations now where tyler stevenson and
luis castillo may need to rethink things
there's a broken batliner back to
castillo he makes the catch flips to
first double play
alfaro doubled off of first on the
broken bad line drive right back at the
pitcher ryan de la cruz the o2 by
castillo swing gonna miss a bad one at
that by brian de la cruz and
castillo now has a couple of them
neither was a second round draft pick by
the seattle mariners in 2015.
swinging and a miss took something off
and he's got back-to-back strikeouts
here in the third luce castillo ready to
return to action he will get son diaz to
lead things off for the marlins in the
fourth inning
castillo
looks in has the sign eyeing his
fourth strikeout swing gonna miss and
there it is
got him with a chain chop down and
asandia strikes out for the second time
tonight that's 4-4 castillo
jesus aguilar stands in now castillo
has the sign wines fires the 2-2 pitch
swing gonna miss struck him out
that was a fastball away from the
right-handed hitting aguilar and he
swings right through it
back-to-back strikeouts for castillo
and the marlins have jorge alfaro up
here
with the infield hit in the second
inning
and he bats again here in the fourth
two down two on for the marlins no score
alfaro swings here and he drives the
ball out into right center it's scooped
up by castellanos and coming around to
score the lead runner jesus sanchez one
to nothing marlins here in the fourth
now alex jackson will stand in jackson
lined out into a double play
and his first and batty broke his bat
lining it right back to the pitcher
castillo the one-two pitch swing and a
miss and down on strikes
alex jackson that's six strikeouts for
castillo but
the marlins strike first
with two outs single walk single that's
the marlins the game's first run one to
nothing miami as we go to the bottom of
the fourth two on one out and now joey
votto votto flew out to the center
fielders first time up i think really
vato had just missed one in that at-bat
tavato has done exceedingly well with
men in scoring position
this year 333 career 327.
tonight a blast to right center fail
send them all home
the 27th bomber for joey votto a
go-ahead three-run shot i'd say that was
his pitch well neither is not getting
that one back
two outs and now kyle farmer
farmer currently on a seven-game hit
streak but in his first at bat he ground
it out to the first baseman
hard ripped by farmer deep to right
sanchez
he won't get there
windmill is on for stevenson
he storms in
no throw
four one reds the reds have a three-run
lead for castillo who comes to the plate
two on and two out
he gets the strikeout of castillo
in the inning
four runs including a three-run homer by
joey votto an rbi double by kyle farmer
and it's four to one reds we go to the
fifth at great american ballpark
now this is the man you want right here
at issan diaz he
has struck out a couple of times the
payoff pitch
swing to the miss struck him out he
challenged him with a fastball and he
blew it by sandias third time tonight
that he has been a strikeout victim
so the inning comes to a close castillo
has struck out seven over the first five
innings halftime at great american ball
park reds four my marlins one
kyle farmer will bat
farmer extended a hitting streak to
eight games with that rbi double in the
fourth all of the red scoring took place
in the fourth three run homer by votto
rbi double by
farmer
and farmer bats here one for two on the
night
from the set detweiler
kicks deals and the ball is pulled on a
line right to the shortstop miguel rojas
he's got it and that's it for the reds
in inning number six
now with two outs and two on miguel
rojas the owner of a couple of the eight
hits that marlins have had two balls two
strikes two outs brenson does not go
swung on that's the ground ball to
mustaches the step to throw right on the
money and
castillo is out of the inning they'll
strand a couple they did not score we go
to the top of the bottom of the seventh
reds will have a 4-1 lead and try to add
a little bit to that
hat upsteps jonathan india
india's had a good night after a ground
ball robbed play by the third baseman
brian anderson robbed them with a base
hit in the first inning he did get a
base hit in the left field his second
time up in the fourth
came around to score and he has walked
in the fifth
india delivers a rope to left down base
hit
aquino rips around third he scores
jonathan india three clean reaches
tonight
doubles home insurance it's 5-1 and up
steps nick castiano's
castiana's through the hole base hit
wave is on india scores
two hits for nick castellanos to give
him a rib eye a two spot the zenning
it's six
nobody on two away
and the batter is alex jackson
the reds start the series the right way
with a convincing win
as they dump the ball in six to one
you